so in order to make a a a wormhole
you're prying open the fabric of space
and time and it would be a hole between
where you are in some other place in
SpaceTime I was on a the trucker channel
on SiriusXM this past weekend if
wormholes become
ubiquitous then you would not need
trucks you would just open a wormhole
from where you are to where the thing
has to be and pass it through you
wouldn't need roads you wouldn't need
trucks you wouldn't need dri the back of
your refrigerator would connect to the
grocery the grocery would look through
oh your milk is going bad let me swap
that out you need another dozen eggs
close up the back and you're done we we
appreciate having Neil de grass Tyson on
the trucker Channel that'll be all
that'll be all for today on the trucker
channel that Neil just destroyed and and
then the phone rings five minutes later
uh this is the head of the teamers Union
exactly